now open your mouth you guys use
snapchat all the time right oh yeah no
I'm 32 I've never so you're very
familiar with all the new updates oh yes
there's so much fun all the new filters
I'd like to try yes please what this is
gonna do we're gonna scan your face yeah
and now you just hold the button down
and record I remember one time I was
deep in the Candyland forest and all of
a sudden oh you snapped at you
ah oh god it's like it feels like the
time I did mushrooms I have taken many
drugs and my eyes are full of watery
worms is entropy licking my face
I got escaped building is collapsing
whoa records it yeah do you want us max
no man I've never used it before I'm
gonna add these to my story so that
everyone thinks I'm hanging out with
cool people you're doing great buddy I
don't know if I like that too much all
right man hey thanks so much I
appreciate anyone oh yo snapchat yeah
you snapped at you think I will use
snapchat I'm trying to think of which of
my friends are hip enough to use it
maybe I'll get them all on it I am gonna
use snapchat now well we've changed the
life today that's all I can ever ask for